this is jocko podcast number 286
with echo charles and me jocko willink
good evening echo good evening and also
joining us again dave burke
good evening dave good evening so
if you haven't listened to 285
just go back and listen to 285 right now
we are
exploring some of the works of bh
liddell
hart i explain who he is on 285
he's a british soldier world war one
military theorist military historian
wrote influenced
he's a he's an influencer he's kind of
an
og influencer really a pioneer and he
legit was he had
a lot of influence inside the british
military he had
influence in all kinds of different
military
organizations including some enemy
military organizations that actually
listened to what he had to say
so if you haven't listened to 285 yet go
back listen to 285
and we're going to jump right back in to
his book which is called strategy it's a
we the last one we covered was the
strategy of the indirect approach
this look everything he does is tied
into the strategy of indirect approach
and and we're going to jump back into
this his other book well he's got many
books
one of his other books called simply
strategy
bh liddell heart here we go dave
anything before i
just jump right into this thing no let's
do it okay so
we're going to get into a section here
called basis of strategy
and i think it's very interesting how
this one kicks off a deeper truth to
which fock
and other disciples of klaus fritz did
not penetrate fully
is that in war every problem and every
principle
is a duality
like a coin it has two faces so this may
remind you of another book you might
have heard of called the dichotomy of
leadership
there you go again i think i owe this
guy some royalties
i did no i mean i could have called the
book the duality of leadership but i
didn't
right we called the dichotomy of
leadership like a coin it has two faces
hence the need for well a
well-calculated
compromise as a means to reconciliation
what does that mean be balanced big
shocker
this is the inevitable consequence of
the fact that war is a two-party affair
so imposing the need that while hitting
one
must guard this just
that you got to balance the dichotomies
of leadership you can't just be on a
total offense you got to have your guard
up you can't just
have your guard up you got to go on
offense you got to be balanced it's a
corollary that
in order to hit with effect the enemy
must be taken off his guard
effective concentration can only be
obtained when the opposing forces
are dispersed and usually in order to
ensure this
one's own forces must be widely
distributed thus by an
outward paradox true concentration
is the product of dispersion so isn't
this interesting
we have to concentrate our forces but we
have to disperse our forces in order to
dis dislocate and put the enemy off
balance
so there's a dichotomy we have to be
together so we can act effectively but
we have to be spread out so we can put
the enemy off balance
what happens if we get too far spread
out well now we're now we're weak
what happens if we're too concentrated
well now we can't disperse the we can't
dislocate the enemy
a further consequence of the two-party
condition
is that to ensure reaching an objective
one should have
an alternative objective or
alternative objectives plural
herein lies a vital contrast to the
single
minded 19th century doctrine of fock
and his fellows a contrast of the
practical
to the theoretical for if the enemy is
certain as to your point of aim
he has the best possible chance of
guarding himself
and blunting your weapon this is why in
jiu-jitsu you have to do more than one
move you can't just grab the arm and
think you're gonna get the arm lock it's
not gonna work
if on the other hand you take a line
that threatens
alternative objectives you distract his
mind
and his forces this moreover is the most
economic method of distraction for it
allows you to keep the largest
proportion of your force
available on your real line of operation
thus reconciling the greatest possible
concentration
with the nes the necessity of dispersion
so you have to have some different
objectives if you just grab the arm
that's not gonna if you just flank if
you're like okay hey
we're gonna flank the enemy okay the
enemy goes oh wait looks like they're
moving over there cool now we adjust our
forces and now that
flank becomes the front so you have to
have multiple objectives now what if you
go to flank and they think oh that's not
just a
that's just a fake move so now they
don't put their forces world then you
attack it
but if you only have one objective
and the enemy recognizes what that is
they're going to defend it heavily
and you're not going to be able to
achieve victory
the absence of an alternative is
contrary to the very nature of war
it sins against the light which borset
shed in the 18th century by his most
penetrating dictum
that quote every plan of campaign
ought to have several branches and to
have been
so well thought out that one or the
other of the said branches
cannot fail of success
so you got to have multiple branches
and they should be well enough thought
out that one of them is going to work
one of one of those branches one of
those lines of operation
is going to work this was the light
that his military heir the young
napoleon bonaparte
followed in seeking always as he said
you guys want me to go french uh yeah
kind of
uh fair son fame
endure fascions
there you go yeah what does that mean it
means
make your theme in two ways you you've
got to have two different approaches
and it's just he calls it it's a sin
against the
the old dictums right which was a god
you gotta have a focus you gotta aim for
that
concentrate your forces in one spot it's
like cool what if the enemy defends that
one spot
you're screwed in technical terms
seventy years later sherman was to
relearn the lesson from experience by
reflection and coin
his infamous maxim about quote putting
the enemy on the horns of a dilemma
end quote in any problem where an
opposing force exists
and cannot be regulated one must foresee
and provide for alternative courses
adaptability is the law which governs
survival and war
as in life war being a concentrated
war being but a concentrated form of the
human struggle against the environment
thank you amplified
intensified but nonetheless
a concentrated form of the human
struggle
to be practical any plan must take
account of the enemy's power to
frustrate it
the best chance of overcoming such an
obstruction
is to have a plan that can be easily
varied to fit the circumstances met i
mean i just was saying this today on ef
online like
you got to have a flexible plan you got
to have a flexible plan
and you'd think that seems super obvious
but you know what you know what people
want to control
and they want to eliminate the unknown
and how do you eliminate the unknown you
come up with a plan
well guess what they're still unknown
even when you have a plan and the more
rigid
you make a plan the less adaptable and
flexible it becomes
which is bad
to keep such adaptability while keeping
the initiative the best way is to
operate along a line which
offers alternative objectives
for thereby you put your opponent on the
horns of a dilemma
which goes far to assure the gaining of
at least
one objective whichever is the least
guarded and may enable you to gain the
other one afterwards
boom in the tactical field where the
enemy's dispositions are likely to be
based on the nature of the ground
it may be more difficult to find a
choice of dilemma-producing objectives
than it is in the strategical field
where the enemy will have obvious
industrial and railway centers to cover
but you can gain
a similar advantage by adapting your
line of effort to the degree of
resistance that is met
and exploiting any weaknesses is found a
plan
like a tree must have branches if it is
to bear fruit
a plan with a single aim is apt to prove
a barren
pole
i'm just thinking of this idea of of
having multiple objectives
and then the dilemma that causes and
even just in in like
aviation terms like we go out on a
mission and our objective is to destroy
enemy air defenses
sam sites or mobile sams whatever those
might be but it's actually reliant on
them to have those systems active and
operating because how you find them if
they're shut down in the dormant you
actually can't find them they're not
radiating they're not
uncovered you can fly around and not
have them there but
if they don't have their sam systems or
air defense systems active
then the things that they're defending
are vulnerable so the secondary mission
we'd have these things called a tpl a
target priority list if these things
aren't there cool
go to this those things aren't there
cool go to this and sooner or later one
will be exposed
and as you start to attack those
defended positions like bridges or roads
or things that matter better turn on
those radars turn on the radar that's
exactly right
and that idea that we would
have multiple target priorities which
all eventually are designed to
lead us back to the number one priority
which might not get on that mission but
we get in the next wave or the next wave
and sooner or later they're stuck in a
place like well if we don't turn these
things on we're going to lose all of our
critical infrastructure and there's
nothing to defend
and creating that dilemma by having
multiple objectives on each flight
yeah and in the business world this this
whole concept
is we hear um
we hear debates or arguments against
this right
you got to have a clear objective and
that makes sense
i tell people that we got to make sure
we understand what the objective is
that being said we also don't want to
have a single point of failure
where hey you know what we're going to
put we're going to make one product yeah
we're going to make one product and if
this product does this product is the
one we're going to put all of our
money all of our birds in this basket
eggs all our eggs are going to go in
this basket don't do that
don't do that don't put all your eggs in
one basket that's that's there you go
never mind bh liddell hart whichever
farmer thought of that one
after his kid dropped the the the basket
full of eggs right
he's like hey kid don't put all your
eggs in one basket
put them in two baskets same thing it's
the exact same thing
yes sir and yet we can get focused on
one objective
and as soon as you meet resistance if
you're not ready to switch to another
one like dave burke
flying you know up there and going home
there's nothing really to shoot at cool
what's the next objective bridges let's
go rock and roll
okay so now we're gonna roll a new
section called cutting communications
in planning any stroke at the enemy's
communications
either by maneuver around his flank or
by rapid penetration
of a breach in his front the question
will arise as to the most effective
point of aim whether it should be
directly against
the immediate rear or the opposing of
the opposing force or further back
when studying the question so again and
i talked about this before
uh on the last podcast is
every time it talks about communications
it's an it's it's telling you
hey you better you better keep your
communication
open when we talk about attacking the
enemies communications and that's how we
cause unbalance and that's how we kind
of crush them
great we're glad to know that that's
also a reminder to us
as leaders that communication is so
paramount to getting our job done
when he's got a whole section called
cutting communication guess what that
should mean to us
from a red cell perspective don't let
your communication get cut
and yet we work with companies all the
time where the communication isn't
open and it's not flowing and people on
the front lines don't know what's
happening
and the people in the head shed don't
get the feedback that they should be
getting from the front lines there's not
communication
happening and yet there's a whole
section here about cutting communication
and you're allowing
your communications to be cut when
there's not even an enemy it's not like
your competitor got into your
email system or got into your phone
system and didn't let you call your
front line leadership that didn't happen
you failed to do it
so where do we cut the communication
when studying this question at the time
that experimental mechanized forces were
first created this and their strategic
use was under consideration i saw
guidance on it
by anal by analysis of cavalry raids
carried out in the past especially in
the more recent wars
since railways came into use while such
cavalry raids had more limited
potentials
than a deep strategic penetration of
mechanized forces seemed to me
to promise that this difference
emphasized rather than detracted
from making the significant evidence
which they provided
making the necessary adjustment the
following deductions could be drawn
and i'm going to kind of burn through
this section
the overall concept is that the nearer
to the force that the cut is made the
more immediate the effect
and the nearer to the base the greater
the effect it's common sense right if
you kill the
the node at the headquarters they can't
communicate to anybody
but it's going to take a while for that
impact to hit the front lines for them
to actually not know what's going on
whereas if you cut the front line node
that immediate node is kind of messed up
so that's the that's the general
consensus
that he gets into there um
he goes on to say these deductions were
confirmed by the experience of the
second war
above all the catastrophic the
catastrophically paralyzing effect
physically and psychologically that was
produced
when great gordian's panzer forces
racing
far ahead of the main german armies
severed the allied army's communications
where these crossed the far back line of
the psalm
and this is where you run into problems
so catastrophically paralyzing when we
start to cut off communications so look
are you going to go into your
competitors you know headquarters and
destroy their their their internet and
their email no you're not going to do
that
but are you allowing that to happen just
by just by human nature
and laziness and no lack of prioritizing
execute are you going to allow your
communications to fall apart there's a
decent chance you are we work with
companies all the time that
aren't communicating they might as well
have had
uh panzer forces go and cut off their
email between their front lines and them
because there's no email happening
there's no conference calls happening
there's no text happening
we don't know what's going on we've lost
communications not through enemy action
but through our own
fault yeah and and
one of the ways one of the places we see
that with business is that the
communication is a one-way
communication where i am i am dictating
or directing or communicating to you i'm
transmitting and there's no
response to that transmission there's no
the communication really isn't designed
for me to hear what you have to say it's
for me to tell you what to do and how to
do it and when to do it and
where to do these things and i get that
compliance
but i don't get that communication which
is a a
a almost guarantee that sooner or later
when then when there is friction with
that
without that communication that plan is
going to fail um
even when i was just talking about
communication i said you're not getting
the you're not getting the
information the front lines and you're
not getting the feedback you need yeah
which is
what you just said it's like hey
communication is supposed to go in two
ways
that's what's supposed to be happening
if we don't let it happen we're going to
have problems
we're going to have problems and in the
in making this relevant to
to the civilian world of the private
sector the
the needle the bias needle of the
communication would be to transmit as
little as possible and and receive as
much as possible
when i have when when i have my team
communicating to me
more than i'm committing to
communicating to them here's what we're
seeing here's what we're doing here's
the problems we're having here's how
we're
saying that's what you would want that's
how would you you would set up the bias
yes the biases if i see that i'm the as
the leader doing 90
of the communication the needle is in
the wrong direction
and so the ability for my people to
communicate to me for me
to hear from them what they're doing
what they're seeing where they are
and i'm doing less communicating to them
than they are communicating up to me
that's where i want that needle that
falls into something i was talking about
the other day on on our online platform
i used this term and both it struck i
think both you and
leif because you've never heard me say
it before i started using the term
traditional leadership
yeah and then like an archetypical
leadership
what does that mean well when we think
of a leader what do we think of like if
you just say oh what does a leader do
well a leader gives orders a leader
talks a leader tells everyone what's
going on they tell people what to do
that's traditional leadership
and actually in my mind if i'm doing
that sort of traditional leadership
i've made 47 mistakes to get to a point
where i have to tell you what's going on
i have to give orders i have to
uh give you direction about where to go
and what to do i've made so many
mistakes if i'm doing that traditional
leadership
role of like all right here's what we're
doing does that happen sometimes and
that was what i was talking about right
the case does sometimes happen where we
got a leadership vacuum no one
knows what to do there's some confusion
and sometimes we do have to take a role
as a traditional leader
step in tell everyone what to do this is
what we're doing this direction we're
having heading
and in a traditional leadership role i'm
in charge i'm the one that's putting out
the word
we want to flip the script on that to
what to your point
traditional leadership is not what my
ideal is
ideal leadership is dave's actually
giving me information
and telling me what's going on and i
have to give very little communication
back because he already understands the
commander's intent and what his roles
were and he by the way knows more about
what's happening on his front than i do
totally
and he's trying to inform me but still
he's there
so that that traditional leadership
versus ideal leadership
is is something to pay attention to
and if you had whatever version of a
catastrophic communication
failure exists where you know it doesn't
have to be the phone lines in combat but
some something that prevents you from
communicating
if your people can't operate based on
your intent with zero communication
and just go out there and execute until
somehow that communication line is
reopened for whatever reason
that again that is a that is your
failure as a leader that they
don't know what to do if you're not
there to tell them what to do
so i don't you know in whatever world
you're in your version of
a communication cutoff your people
should still be able to execute
next little section called the method of
advanced until the end of the 18th
century a
physically concentrated advance both
strategic to the battlefield and
tactical
on the battlefield was the rule
then napoleon exploiting borsei's
ideas and new divisional system
introduced a
distributed strategic advance the army
moving in
independent but fractions
tactical advance was still in general a
concentrated one
this is you know we start getting into
decentralized command and
you know i mentioned borse already
b-o-u-r-c-e-t he's
another french general um 1700s
i think he yeah born in 1700 died in
1780 but
this is another guy that that had a
little bit of vision
right had a vision about decentralized
command and that's kind of
one of them this divisional system where
you can start to get people to move
on their own and that is a better way to
advance
back to the book toward the end of oh
and by the way to dave's point
we know where we're going and if you
lose if if you got your division and
echo's got his division and
carrie's got his division and you lose
columns with me it doesn't matter three
days later you're where you're supposed
to be because you knew where you were
going yeah
back to the book towards the end of the
19th century with the development of
fire weapons the tactical advance became
dispersed i.e and particles to diminish
the effective fires this is when we
really start to get to
dispersion but the strategic advance had
become
concentrated this would do partly to the
influence of railways and growth of the
masses
partly to the misunderstanding of the
napoleonic methods so
when when we started to use machine guns
well then people started
dispersing tactically but because of
trains we were moving these mass groups
together
a revival of the distributed advance was
required in order to revive the art
and effective strategy moreover new
conditions
air power and motor power point to its
further development
into a dispersed strategic advance
the danger of air attack the aim of
mystification
and the need of drawing full value from
mechanized mobility
suggests that advancing forces should
not only be distributed as widely as
as is compatible with combined action
but
be dispersed as much is compatible
with cohesion so what they're saying
there's a balance that you have to have
we got to be as far apart as we possibly
can
but as long as we're still a cohesive
unit
that's the dichotomy that you have to
balance
this becomes essential in the face of
atomic weapons obviously we can't be all
together because we're going to get
nuked
sure and it's crazy that we sit here and
chuckle at that
because for us it's almost like hey that
couldn't happen
but hey and we've covered we've covered
uh some significant military manuals
where they talk about
the actual they're planning on how
they're gonna maneuver when
the enemy is using tactical nukes
which is crazy to think about uh
the development of radio has a timely
aid towards reconciling
dispersion with control instead of the
simple idea of concentrated stroke
by a concentrated force we should choose
according to
circumstance between these variants it
gives some some op
some some options here dispersed advance
with concentrated single aim
i.e against wanted objective dispersed
advance with concentrated
serial aim which which means when we get
there we're going to go off their
multiple
successive objectives dispersed advance
with distributed aim
i.e against a number of objectives
simultaneously
the effectiveness of armies depends on
the development of such new methods
methods which aim at permeating and
dominating areas rather than capturing
lines
at the practicable object of paralyzing
the enemy's action rather than the
theoretical object
of crushing his forces
fluidity of forces may succeed where
concentration of force
merely entails rigidity a perilous
rigidity so at times
bruce lee sure we want to be like water
fluidity of force is sometimes better
than just concentration of force
if you can move jeff glover on the jiu
jitsu mats
you you grab something on him and he's
somewhere else
you grab something on dean he's
countering
right you grab something on jeffy glover
he's maneuvering like
he's gone it's like a a piece of
sir yeah you squeeze one part he pops
out another part
yes right with dean you can't squeeze
like it doesn't go anywhere he does the
squeezing yeah
you're getting squeezed that's the way
it worked
all right just the word fluid and i
mentioned it before i talk about fluid
mutual support just the idea of
of being fluid is its flexibility it's
the ability to be reactive to the
situation
in a way that puts you in a place to be
available to support as you need it
but far enough away to maneuver as you
need to and i just i think the idea of
of in this era them talking about fluid
when the backdrop of world war one and i
know we've hit this a thousand times the
backdrop of
world war one was was whatever the
opposite of fluid
is which is this inca the inability
the inability to to to adjust to
maneuver to do something
you that that analogy you just did with
like that slime thing of
i squeeze here and something pops it
over there that the being the ability to
be fluid
and the the inherent
the the way you'd want to describe your
organization or your your reaction to
things going on in your organization
being fluid
and how quickly people get to being
rigid with their thought processes their
ideas
their objectives what they want to
accomplish and how quickly
it becomes rigid so
so check this out we're in world war one
okay we actually have
a culture that views
fluidity as weakness
the victorian culture if you want to run
away from danger
you're a coward you're weak
now take that and bring a thread to the
board room
bring a thread to the conference room
and accompany
and if dave presents an idea to me
and i back down because i agree with his
idea or i back down because i oh i see
some holes in my idea
i might be viewed as weak so i'm not
going to be fluid instead i'm going to
be rigid i'm going to stand up to dave
we're going to fight about it
and by the way if i out rank you i'm
gonna win
it's freaking ridiculous crazy but we
have this culture
and and that culture you know look the
culture the reason that culture exists
especially the culture of rigidity
is directly tied to our human nature our
ego right
because we feel like oh i don't wanna
i'm not gonna back down to dave
i'm not gonna let that happen it's like
actually
you know what good call dave i like your
idea better
the the odd thing about this is that it
makes me look stronger
it makes me look open-minded and
flexible and
confident to be like you know what dave
like your idea let's roll with that
the whole room the whole freaking
conference room goes damn
taco's got some confidence he's good
with whatever plan he just wants us to
win
as opposed to actually dave you know
what i've heard enough from you
we're going with my plan everyone in the
room goes oh he's weak
i think i'm strong i'm being weak and
everybody perceives me as weak
everybody pers this is the car one of
the hardest lessons to learn
it's one of the hardest lessons to learn
is that
flexibility is viewed as a strength
fluidity is viewed as a strength putting
your ego and being humble is viewed as
strength
and when you do the opposite when you're
rigid it's viewed as weakness when you
let your ego flare up it's viewed as
weakness it's viewed as insecurity
and we see this all day long we see this
all day long
check next chapter
the concentrated essence of strategy
and tactics
do i own royalties for my book do i i
think i kind of first i was like nah but
then
now i think maybe to the to the um
to the children and descendants of bhl
dill heart
unfortunately for you this book was
published over 50 years ago so
we are cleared and i apologize
but that's where we're at
hopefully people will buy this book and
you'll get some support
it's uh fantastic this brief chapter is
an attempt to epitomize
from the history of war and as soon as
you hear this dave you're going to kind
of be like oh here we go
this brief chapter is an attempt to
epitomize from the history of war
a few truths of experience which seems
so universal and so
fundamental as to be termed axioms
they are practical guides not abstract
principles
napoleon realized that only the
practical is useful when he gave us his
maxims
but the modern tendency which we we'll
put i'm not gonna ask you we covered the
napoleon's maxims
on this podcast you can google it since
echo does not know
nor do i check
the modern tendency has been to search
for principles which can be expressed in
a single word
and then need several thousands words to
explain them
even so these principles are so abstract
that they may mean different things to
different men
and for any value depend on the
individual's own
understanding of war the longer one
continues to search for
such omnipotent abstra abstractions
the more do they appear a mirage neither
attainable
nor useful except as an intellectual
exercise
these principles of war not merely one
principle can be condensed into a single
word
concentration so he's saying this word
concentration which we all
learn concentration of forces he's
saying you could say all these
principles and put them in the word
concentration okay let's start there
but for the but for truth this needs to
be amplified as
the concentration of strength against
weakness
and for any real value it needs to be
explained that the concentration of
strength against weakness depends on the
dispersion of your opponent's strength
which in turn is produced by a
distribution of your own that gives the
appearance
and partial effect of dispersion your
dispersion
his dispersion your concentration such
as the sequence
and equal and each is a sequel true
concentration is a force of calculated
dispersion so he's saying even though
it's really easy to say
concentration it's like oh there's a lot
more going on than that yeah
here we have a fundamental principle
whose
understanding may prevent a fundamental
error
and the most common that of giving your
opponent
freedom and time to concentrate to meet
your concentration
this is why when you cover and move you
put down covering fire
and then the other element moves why
it's that covering fire that doesn't
allow the enemy to
maneuver to meet your concentration
but to state that the prince but to
state the principle
is not much practical aid for execution
the above mentioned axioms here
expressed as maxims cannot be condensed
into a single word
but they can be put into the fewest
words necessary to be practical
eight in all so far six are positive
eight and all so far it's interesting
he's saying like hey this is probably
gonna change
but this is where we're at so far six
are positive and two are negative
they apply to tactics as well as strat
strategy unless otherwise indicated
number one and these are the positive
ones
number one adjust your end
to your means
adjust your end to your means
this is another thing that's you got to
know your objective
you got to stick to your objective he's
actually saying look man you gotta make
some adjustments
your your end may change based upon your
means and here's what he says
in determining your object
clear sight and cool calculation should
prevail wouldn't that be nice
it is folly to quote bite off more than
you can chew
end quote and the beginning of military
wisdom
is a sense of what is possible
that's the beginning of military wisdom
what's actually possible
and this is where you you know you can
get into some um
you know theoretical ideas about but if
you believe it it's like
no and it's actually interesting i
remember the early musters i got asked
about this and
i explained belief as
seeing an actual pathway to victory
you you've got a belief means you can
actually see a
an actual pathway a viable pathway to
achieve what you're talking about
because to think you know what i want to
be an astronaut
like right now i'm 49 years old
i guess i could figure out
no not really i probably have a better
chance of becoming an astronaut than uh
an nba player right same
so is there okay same thanks for the
support bro
is there a viable pathway for me to
become an nba player
not really not really
so therefore i need to adjust the end
a little bit find something a little
more feasible he goes on to say
so learn so learn to face
facts while still pervert preserving
faith
there will be ample need for faith the
faith that can achieve the apparent
impossible when action begins so look we
gotta have a positive attitude
confidence is like the current in a
battery avoid exhausting it in vain
effort and remember that your own
continued confidence will be of no avail
if the cells of your battery the men
upon
whom you depend have been run down
so this is a again there's very few
people that would think that the
military mind
should focus on hey i might have to
adjust what i'm trying to get to
because it seems like the military is
you know like
we're gonna get this done like no
this is the number one the number one
axiom he's talking about
adjust your end to your means number two
keep your object always in mind now this
is a dichotomy right
keep your app your object always in mind
while adapting your plan to
circumstances
realize that there are more we realize
that there are more ways than one of
gaining an object
an object but take heed that every
objective
should bear on the object
and in considering this just just real
quick
if you as a leader can understand the
fact
that there's more ways than one of
gaining an object your life just got a
thousand times more easy
just got a thousand times easier i've
seen
countless leaders
think that they know the way and want to
do something a certain way and
waste time and effort
and resources and most important waste
leadership capital
to get something done a certain way when
my attitude is like
i don't care i don't care how you want
to get this done
i don't care this is what we want to get
done how do you want to do it cool
sounds good it's a viable plan it's a
minimally
viable plan dave's plan you know what i
might do it differently
dave's plan looks like it could work too
cool and by the way
do we know your plan is going to work
perfectly no we don't do i know my plan
is going to work perfectly no we don't
so why am i going to invest a bunch of
resources and
time and effort and arguing and
leadership capital trying to convince
you
to use my plan instead of your plan when
they're both a freaking gamble
don't waste your time
connecting connecting those two those
two i guess axioms together or those
those those fundamental things from a
leadership standpoint of and we even
talked about this
you know from as a leader showing people
a
path to the to the end state that might
not happen today might happen tomorrow
but it's it's possible if you're gonna
say hey
let's bring in the three of us we're
gonna we're gonna be a 100 million
dollar company
and i've got no way to show you how
that's going to happen
other than uh either just belief or
faith or or hope for a miracle um or
hey this one product this is gonna be
we're gonna have this magical product
and this is gonna work
and i could also say hey listen
our goal we want to be a 100 million
dollar company but let me tell you
what what's gonna what we're gonna have
to do right now we're not
but we're gonna do this and this and
that's gonna allow us to bring in
this other group maybe getting an
acquisition here and you can start to
lay out this path and people and i've
seen it in those rooms where you see the
leaders
lay out the path to getting there not
the exact steps we're going to take but
what
we and all of a sudden people go oh oh
yeah we can we can do that and that's
going to lead to this and then we bring
in more people and we bring in more
resources we bring in
another company that does this just
laying out the steps
so people in their minds understand and
i and i'm just saying this because of
the word
viable the the the the value of people
saying oh that's actually not crazy what
you're saying is not this
magic crazy pipe dream i can actually
see how
if we do this and then if i on that
second step
as a subordinate leader understand what
you're trying to accomplish
and you're not here saying turn left to
your return right here do this and not
telling me what to do
or how to do it you're just telling me
the end state that we want
then i actually get to be the one that
drives us to that goal that is actually
so much more believable now
because it's viable because you laid
that out and then let me
let me move towards that objective
here's a detail that i just picked up on
taking what you said when you said uh
what i said back to me and i was like oh
there's an
there's an error in what i said
when i when i say a belief is
seeing a path to victory
what it should actually be is seeing
paths plural to victory and the reason i
thought of this is because as you're
sitting here talking about well
if i say okay dave we're gonna make a
hundred million dollar company
and you go oh that sounds awesome i'm in
yeah uh but how are we gonna do that and
i lay out
one single path to get us there
yeah you know that that's cool and
everything but your your faith in that
is gonna go down a little bit but if i
say hey listen
here's our five different lines of
operations
and here's what each one of these things
are gonna produce
and you know what chances are dave one
or two of these might fail completely
they're good ideas i like them but we
don't haven't gone far enough down them
to really understand but
we know that of these ideas we have made
some progress in all of them and we see
potential
so if two or three of these paths go the
way we want them to
we're going to be right where we want to
be we're going to get that 100 million
so
even you know going back to the last
podcast
having multiple avenues of approach
is highly beneficial to your belief
system
being distributed and how you go to an
objective
right yeah right having more than one
having more than one pathway to that
objective
yeah and by the way also saying look we
might
we might not make this one objective
over here but we're still going to get
where we want to be
same maxim here continue on and in
considering possible
objectives weigh their possibility of
attainment
with their service to the object if
attained
to wander down a side track is bad but
to reach a dead end is worse
so especially if the dead end is the
only pathway that you've got yeah that's
why having a couple different pathways
is smart
number three choose the line or course
of least
expectation try to put yourself in the
enemy's shoes and think what course is
least probable
he will foresee or forestall
number four exploit the line of least
resistance
so long as it can lead you to any
objective
which would contribute to your
underlying object
right oh yeah it's cool path least
resistance but it's got to be going in
the right direction
in tactics this maximum applies to the
use of your reserves and in strategy the
exploitation
of tactical success number five
take a line of operation which offers
alternative objectives
okay sorry we went a little ahead on
that one
for you will thus put your opponent on
the horns of dilemma
which comes from the last podcast which
goes far to assure the chance of gaining
one objective at least
whichever he guards least and may enable
you to gain
one after the other because once you get
one like we make it in one line of
operation
and now we made a bunch of money cool
guess what we can invest in that other
thing that was a little bit harder out
of the gate but
now we have the money to spend on it and
we can make it happen yeah
alternative objectives allow you to keep
the opportunity of
gaining an objective whereas a single
objective unless the enemy is helplessly
inferior
means the certainty that you will not
gain it once the enemy is no longer
uncertain as to your aim as soon as the
enemy knows what you're doing
your chances of success go down
dramatically unless they're
helplessly inferior there is no more
common mistake than to confuse a single
line of operation
which is usually wise with a single
objective
which is usually futile
number six and the last of the positive
maxims
ensure that both plans and dispositions
are flexible
adaptable to circumstances and by
dispositions that's like where you're
putting people
your plans should foresee and provide
for a next step in case of success or
failure or a partial success which is
the most common case in war your
dispositions or formation should be
such as to allow this exploitation or
adaptation in the shortest possible time
you know people people will argue and
fight
and struggle with trying to figure out
how they're going to task organize
organize a group of people like well no
actually dave i think this person should
report to dave and this person should
report to leif and this person should
report to me
we can argue about that stuff i'll wait
all day long
and by the way you're pissed i'm pissed
and guess what
it's our company and i go you know what
dave
you go ahead that person can report you
cool that sounds good
and you look up at me in two weeks and
you're like hey this doesn't really make
much sense
okay cool they can report you know like
you don't it's not set in stone you
don't get a tattoo on your forehead of
your task organization
and by the way it doesn't look quote
look bad to say
hey you know what fred you're gonna be
working for dave and then a month later
say hey fred seems like your expertise
is really gonna be a little bit more
beneficial to leif and what he's got
going on
we're gonna shift you over there no do
you want to do this every two weeks no
obviously not
but to put someone in a position or or
task organize
organize in a certain way and and have
it flexible
flexible dispositions that's exactly
what it is is the smart way to do things
and obviously it's with a flexible plan
as well
the negatives do not throw your weight
into a stroke whilst your opponent is on
guard
whilst he is well placed to parry or
evade it
the experience of history shows that
save against a much inferior opponent no
effective stroke is possible until his
power of resistance or evasion is
paralyzed
hence no commander should launch a real
attack upon an enemy in position until
satisfied that such a
paralysis has developed it is produced
by disorganization
and its moral equivalent demoralization
of the enemy so
cool set it up set up the move
eight and the last one do not renew an
attack along the same line
or in the same form after it has once
failed
a mere reinforcement of weight is not a
sufficient change
for it is probable that the enemy also
will have strengthened itself
in the interval it is even more probable
that his success
in repulsing you will have strengthened
immorally um
it's one of my favorite coaching moves
in jiu jitsu
is uh you know do it harder i was i was
saying that to carry
the other day like he's like grabbing
your wrist
i could grab that thing harder it hasn't
helped him for six minutes
grabbing the wrist while he's in your
guard but if he does it harder
you know that might work that's what
this is like it didn't work
it's not gonna work don't do it harder
just because you add
hey you know we spent a bunch of money
on advertising
uh we haven't seen any bump in our in
our uh
uh sales yeah spend more let's spend
more
i guess the only thing that surprised me
is from the guy who was in world war one
that that wasn't number one yeah like
the first thing he says is hey
don't do what we did for three straight
years
yeah maybe that's why it's his last
point yeah
like hey by the way you freaking idiot
idiots
all this other stuff cool listen you
freaking idiots
if it doesn't work don't keep doing it
if it didn't work with
ten thousand men it's not gonna work
with twenty thousand that's crazy
you can see how you get sucked into that
don't you yeah you're like you know what
the way you get sucked into it is when
you commit yourself to the outcome of
your plan
this plan is going to achieve this
outcome and
if i if i allocate resource i work for
you hey this is the plan is we're going
to do i allocate resources and doesn't
work
well i can either abandon that plan make
me look weak like
oh or i can go hey we're going to
allocate more resources
and more resources and more resources
more resources because i'm inflexible to
say well actually maybe i didn't connect
my
ends to my means to the end and i didn't
do just something
might need to do something different or
regroup or reassess or
come in from a different direction as
opposed to saying hey you know what
that hey boss that plan didn't work let
me take a step back we need to kind of
see what we what we did here with this
marketing scheme
it didn't have the effect that we want
and before we start putting in more
resources let me get a better assessment
of what's going on
and kind of give that to you and it may
be that we do the same thing
but we're probably going to need to make
some changes
yeah at least quantify your efforts
right
it's really disturbing because it really
is one of these things where
it is so tempting when you get close
you get you know you feel like the
pressure like you try an arm lock
and you almost got it you try it again
it's like the person defended it once
the person is going to defend it again
you spend that money in marketing you
spend that money
and you you know you saw a little bit of
an uptick but it's not quite
what you wanted but still maybe we just
put more money into it
and i'm listening i'm listening to you
talk about some of those things
and i'm almost trying to think of of
what is the human nature to do that and
i think some of it is
is we kind of glorify
this single-minded this yeah
i think it's similar things we there's
like this glorification of
i refuse to give in i refuse to to to
give up i refuse to tap i refuse to
accept defeat
and so my answer is i'm just going to
send more
i'm going to send more and more and i
think the times that
that perseverance pays off there's some
sort of like glorification of that
single-mindedness when when in in
reality
how much weaker does it make us look
by being unwilling to say hang on
i think there's a flaw in my plan here
let me let me just
i need i need to take a step back and
rethink this i'm i'm missing something
i'm missing something
and the weakness that that shows and you
were talking about before is you know
that makes you look weak when the exact
opposite is true yeah well
i have a section in leadership strategy
and tactics called when
to quit never
quit actually totally wrong totally
wrong
when do you quit oh this plan that we
have is not working
we lost a guy two guys three guys this
is
stupid let's go a different direction
now just imagine doing that
for battalions and brigades and
divisions of soldiers man it's
free for you crazy it is crazy
just give us a look we just had if we
just would have had another 10 000
soldiers at that moment
god it's so tempting is it like
do you feel like it's maybe like because
it's like you say glorify um
you know never quite that yeah that
never quit and then they over over
simplify it because
you say persistence right persistence
always you know like that's the way this
guy was successful he's just persistent
you know fail fail
and by the way dichotomy right yeah it's
a dichotomy
like you can say oh you know what it
didn't work the way we wanted to okay
screw it we're gonna go do something
else like so there's a dichotomy in this
right you know even when i was talking
about like you go for the arm lock you
don't get it you go for the arm lock you
don't get it
there's plenty of fights where the
person went for the arm lock three four
times finally they get it
yeah that's what i'm saying where they
oversimplify it where they have all
these cool sayings like you know if
if at first you don't succeed you know
try again or
you know all these things but there's
more to it than that something else
yeah some of the pacific island campaign
hey we should be done with this
operation in three days
cool 19 days later we're not even a
quarter wave where we're
supposed to be
like guess what we're going to send some
more resources there we're going to get
it done
oh man that's why this is even this is a
dichotomy
totally yes so the persistence and the
you know
if at first you don't succeed try and
try again or whatever the
it's persistent not in the same exact
methodology it's like persistence but
you kind of got to make these little
changes within that but you can't really
fit that in the little slogan you know a
lot of the time
i was just gonna say i mean in very
simplistic terms
you know i think that's one of the
differences between the tactics and the
strategy is i will abandon a tactic
and i will give up on a tactic very
quickly
if it if it's the wrong tactic to get to
the now
giving up on a strategy is a very
different thing
but giving up on the tactic or or maybe
it's not even the right word but
adjusting my tactics
and adjusting the plan and getting
feedback from the ones implementing the
plan
while sticking to the strategy or the or
the long-term objective
again very simplistically but the
commitment to the tactic when you see
people committing to the same thing over
and over and over again
as opposed to going hey this tactic
isn't working is there a better way to
do this to accomplish that same
end goal of what we want to become as a
company or as a team
um that difference for me is how often
we see people unwilling to change their
tactic
yeah when it's so obvious that they need
to and that's the exact that's exactly
in that section in leadership strategy
and tactics once i explain like hey
you need to quit what you're doing
that's failing
this doesn't mean you abandon your
overall strategy
that's the actual words that i use i
open it up but that's because that's
that's 100 right
just because i go oh you know what this
doesn't seem to be working right look
when
when in world war one it wasn't hey
this isn't working let's surrender no
it's you know what this isn't working
let's figure out a different way to do
this
let's figure out a different way to
attack
i think it's also just a freaking sanity
check that you need to do
it's neat it's one of these things where
look you beat your i
i used to say this on the podcast uh
my limit for beating my head against the
wall is 47 times
like once i've beat my head against the
wall 47 times like okay
number 44 45 46.
okay 47 this isn't going to work i got
to try something else like you got to
check yourself
what is that number how much you how
much money are you willing to throw into
marketing how big
how many more people are you willing to
give to that leader that's failed
yeah uh how many more projects are you
you know like
there's things where you've got to check
yourself is it have you beat your head
against the wall 47 times any of your
head
have don't go the 48th time
time to re-evaluate your your tactic
doesn't mean you need to abandon what
you're trying to do
means you need to freaking check
yourself
um back to the book the essential truth
underlying these maxims
is that for success two major
problems must be solved dislocation and
exploitation
one precedes and one follows the actual
blow which in comparison is a simple act
so it's pretty easy to hit him but you
got to set up the hit
and you got to exploit the hint once
you've done you cannot hit the enemy
with effect until you have first created
the opportunity you cannot make that
effect decisive unless you exploit the
second opportunity that comes
before he can recover
the pos the importance of these two
problems has never been
adequately recognized a fact which goes
far to explain the common indecisiveness
of warfare
so we don't make decisions because we
don't understand how important it is
that when echoes off balance i better
freaking attack
or before i get them off balance i need
to set them up so i can get them off
balance
the training of armies this is freaking
epic the training of armies is primarily
devoted to developing efficiency
in the detailed execution of the attack
the concentration on tactical technique
tends to obscure the psychological
element
it fosters a cult of soundness
rather than surprise it bleeds it breeds
commanders who are so intent
not to do anything wrong according to
the book
that they forget the necessity of making
the enemy do something wrong
the result is that their plans have no
result
[Music]
for in war it is by compelling mistakes
that the scales are most often turned
gotta make the person make mistakes
here and there a commander has eschewed
the obvious
and is found in unexpected in the
unexpected the
key to a decision unless fortune has
proved foul
for luck can never be divorced from war
since it's part of life
hence the unexpected cannot guarantee
success
but it guarantees the best chance of
that's why we got to surprise people
next section the national object
and military aim and
look we talk about alignment a lot and
this is where inside of an organization
this is this is really talking about
alignment
and so as you you as you hear us discuss
this thinking about
alignment through your organization this
is what we have to be
cognizant of as leaders in discussing
the subject of the objective in war it
is essential to be clear about and keep
clear in our minds the distinction
between the political and military
objective
the two are different but not separate
for nations that
for nations do not wage war for war's
sake
but in pursuance of policy the military
objective is only the means to a
political end
hence the military objective should be
governed by the political objectives
subject to the basic condition
that policy does not demand what is
militarily
that is practically impossible
so what are we trying to do in our
company what are we actually trying to
do inside of our company and if we're
trying to do something inside of our
company does everybody on the team
understand what we're trying to do and
are there maneuvers out there
in support of what it is we're trying to
do
thus any study of the problem ought to
begin and end with a question of policy
the term objective although common usage
is not really a good one it has a
physical and geographical sense
and thus tends to confuse thought it
would be better to speak of the
object when dealing with the purpose of
policy
and of the military aim when dealing
with the way
that forces are directed in the service
of policy
so i mentioned on the first podcast we
did that he kind of goes into this
objective versus object and he uses the
term
object i think it's not it's a little
bit of an archaic way of using it i know
it's only 19 whatever 30.
but for us we use objective all the time
and we definitely use it in a military
sense but to his point
objective we think of like airfield
right
we think of beachhead so
maybe it's a good idea we'll go with it
the object in war
is a better state of peace
even if only from your own point of view
this is a you know i always talk about
climbing the
ladder of alignment this is the highest
you can get in the ladder of alignment
for war
the reason we're in war is because we
want a better piece that's what we're
trying to do
hence it is essential to conduct war
with constant regard
for your for the peace you desire this
is the long
long long term thinking
that applies to both both to aggressor
nations who seek expansion and to
peaceful nations who only fight for
self-preservation
although their views of what is meant by
a better state of peace are very
different
history shows that gaining military
victory is not
in itself equivalent to gaining the
object of policy
but as most of the thinking about war
has been done by men of the military
profession
there has been a very natural tendency
to lose the site of basic
national object and identify it with the
military aim
so how does this happen inside of a
business we start the business the
people that are out there in the field
trying to make things happen
they might lose sight of what it is
we're trying to do
and consequence whenever war is broken
out policy is too often been governed by
the military aim
and this has been regarded as an end in
itself
instead of as a merely a means to an end
fast forward a little bit for more than
a century of
the prime cannon of military doctrine
has been that
has been that quote the destruction of
the
enemy's main forces on the battlefield
constituted the only
true aim in war
that's what war is for just destroy the
enemy destroy the enemy forces on the
battlefield actually
that was universally accepted engraved
in all military manuals and taught
at all staff colleges if any statesman
ventured to doubt whether it fitted the
national object in all circumstances
he was regarded it was regarded as
blasphemy
and violating holy writ as can be seen
in studying the official records and
memoirs of the military
heads of the warring nations
particularly in and after world war one
so absolute a rule would have astonished
the great commanders and teachers of war
theory and ages
prior to the 19th century for they had
recognized the practical necessity of
wisdom of adapting
aims to limitations of strength and
policy
like how long are we gonna try and fight
this thing before i say you know what
this is freaking
not good we're expending all of our
national treasure and we're not getting
anywhere this is a bad call
and now we're going to start hammering
on crossfits again
klaus fitz's influence
the rule acquired its dogmatic rigidity
largely through the posthumous influence
of klaus wits and his books
upon the minds of prussian soldiers
particularly mulkey
and thence more widely through the
impact of their victories in 1866 and
1870 made upon the armies of the world
which copied so many features of the
prussian system
thus it is a vital importance to examine
his theories
as so often happens klaus wits his
disciples
carried his teachings to an extreme
which their master had not intended
misinterpretation has been the common
fate of most prophets
and thinkers in every sphere devout but
uncompromising oh sorry devout but
uncomprehending disciples
have been more damaging to the original
conception than
even its prejudiced and per-blind
opponents
so what what happens we get people that
take things to the extreme
and they do more damage than the people
that are against the idea
it must be admitted however that klaus
wits invited misinterpretation more than
most
sorry klaus fitz a student of kant
at second hand he acquired a
philosophical mode of expression without
developing a truly
philosophical mind ouch sorry dude he's
hammering close what's
there consonants is taking heavies how
are you how
did you guys talk about crossfits in a
positive way in policy school or
mostly i mean the the the pull
from klaus was to the takeaway from that
was there were components inside there
that
the things that he said make sense and
and
he talks about ends and meads he talks
about tactics and strategy and is really
a good tool for people to understand and
the way the context that we're using is
actually i think very important and very
similar to what he's saying is that
the military which has this sort of
outsized recognition this outsize um
uh status of the the the
instead of being a tool to accomplish
the political means of what the state
wants
it it's almost uh it means in and of
itself as if the military exists for the
military
as opposed to this is a tool one of many
tools
that actually accomplishes the political
means which and
to just kind of bring that back a little
bit when he talked about
the object being a greater piece or a
better piece or
or whatever the term that you use and
it's funny because
i think i've evolved in my thinking when
i hear objective
i don't think bridge anymore i don't
think airfield anymore i think goals i
think outcomes so
but i understand his point and i
certainly remember in the beginning of
my military career what's the objective
oh to secure that bridge
or or to to do whatever that particular
thing is
if we've got a company and our company's
object or
our vision our goal is to be
you know the premier hardware producer
for a product that
every company in the world needs for
them to be successful and then i've got
a sales team inside there and everything
well sales is like
the most important thing we have we got
to sell this thing it's the military
version for this company
and you're out there running the sales
team and your objective is sell as many
of these things as you can
because that's obviously how we become
the indispensable producer of this
product that everybody's going to need
and be the most reputable and reliable
company in the world
but if you're out there selling this
product and it hasn't been made yet
because our operations team hasn't stood
up
or you're selling this and we don't have
the support
for the clients that are going to buy it
to actually give them the tools they
need or
you're selling this and we don't have
the software to update it and back it up
you can actually accomplish your
objective by selling this product
that doesn't help us achieve the object
that doesn't actually help us be
successful
and i'm not defending kosovo's but
there is the military has something
somebody's got yeah
it's all good the the military
in some ways has become this tool this
means
that sort of in and of itself is its own
thing like the military exists to defeat
you know to win wars and defeat the
enemy and destroy battlefields
once actually no it's one of several
different ways and when you made that
comment about the military's existence
like
the ideal thing you would think for the
military is i want this military to
exist
to deter any potential opponent from
ever going to war with us
in terms of like what would i want from
a military i don't want i would love to
never
set foot on the battlefield i'd love to
never get now whether or not that's
realistic
but i would love a military force of
people our opponents look
look at and go you know what i'm good
with your plan i like your plan
i'm here to support that plan you want
to use our our bridges and roads to
for commerce and maybe occupy some of my
towns
yeah i let's find a compromise to make
that work as opposed to no this isn't
going to happen
and your military shows up to compel me
to do it in a way that i don't
necessarily want
but the object objective thing and i'm
just trying to make the connection to
to the business world of if you think
you're out there just to do this one
thing and it doesn't support the object
of the company
or the long-term goal you're actually
not successful you're not winning i sold
the most product cool can we support it
no can we build it no can we back it up
no can can the clients get what they
want no
then then we actually aren't successful
what happens to our reputation what
happens to our backlog
we get crushed and and you're gonna see
he he
he goes he goes relatively hard on
crosswords he also
explains some of the things that people
missed which he
he kind of also blames on klaus wits but
there's a lot of things that klaus with
says in the uh
that just aren't as memorable that
aren't as memorable as some of his
really kick-ass statements and people
remember what sounded cool
yeah and if they got mistaken like i
think however many chapters are in on
war i think he wrote like the first
three by himself and they're really well
written and super complete and then
several chapters were written by his
wife after he died and they're like half
done and like
and they've been you know hearts
probably wrote this in english
and colossus was written in some sort of
prussian version that's been translated
a thousand times so
again yeah in his defense yeah and when
you do that translation if you kind of
think that maybe
uh you know concentration and mass is
how to win
you definitely are going to emphasize
that i think this is what he meant and
yeah back to the book his theory of war
was expounded in a way too abstract and
involved for ordinary soldier minds
essentially concrete he's saying the
soldier mines are concrete
to follow the course of his argument
which often turned back from the
direction in which it was apparently
leading
impressed yet before they grasped at his
vivid leading phrases seeing only their
surface meaning and missing the deeper
current of his thought
klauswick's greatest contribution to the
theory of war
was in emphasizing the psychological
factors raising his voice against the
geometrical school strategy then
festival
he showed that the human spirit was
infinitely more important
than operational lines and angles he
discussed the effect
of danger and fatigue the value of
boldness and determination
with deep understanding it was his
errors however which had the greatest
effect on subsequent course of history
he was too continental in his outlook to
understand the meaning of sea
power and his vision was short on the
very threshold of the mechanical era
he did he declared his conviction that
superiority in numbers becomes
every day more decisive yeah so he kind
of was a little bit late they didn't
freaking tank yet one of the classic
discussions was
the the um what's the word i'm looking
for
the relevance of costs was in the 21st
century you know start talking about you
know like
nuclear power your nuclear weapons
stealth airplanes and things like hey
do these maxims of these do these do
they hold up to the scrutiny of
the 21st century of warfare the modern
warfare and a bunch of discussions on
that
i kind of chuckled at the idea of like
his disciples the klaus was disciples
who kind of aren't that smart but
really like what he had to say you know
that'd be like me reading leadership
strategy tactics and there's a chapter
that says don't care and me be like hey
everybody
don't care yeah but getting that wrong
but misunderstanding
like i don't care as opposed to i don't
care how we do it you want to do area i
don't care we'll do it your way
which is a little bit different than
don't care
next thing you know dave burke jocko's
disciple is running around
telling all the rest of his people we
don't care yeah
and i don't care yeah i don't care and
we're now
a bunch of people who don't care and how
easy you could see
a disciple who's and i i'll never
remember the quote but
the the most damage was done by um the
concrete brain
well you said the disciples that the
misunderstanding of his disciples did
way more damage
than the opponents right right because
i'm running around espousing jocko's
you know edicts but actually don't
really know what he meant by don't care
yeah and i'm just using that one example
of kind of pulling from this book of
like a great way of like
i don't care like dude that that is not
what he meant i know that's what it says
on paper but that's not what he was
saying
yeah or like knowing to quit hey man you
know what you gotta throw in the towel
whatever we quickly
give up shut it down yeah
uh uh so he's talking about how
important
oh well i know what i was gonna say i i
was taking a note when you were writing
i only got down the two letters
m a and then i was looking i was like
what the hell was i going to write
i was going to write machine gun because
for me
where the tactics sort of solidified
where you can say yep these things hold
up it's you got to have the machine gun
that's where we start to get the modern
machine gun
where we can start to kill a lot of
people and how concentration
is like the war is the worst thing and
just cover and move becomes totally
important it's it's important in all
eras
but it really starts to solidify around
there
well you use the example of like on
steroids of nuclear weapons you know you
talk about dispersion you know
versus concentration with with nuclear
weapons um i thought of another one just
as i was thinking of it
as hold the line jaco says hold the line
cool got it yeah we're gonna hold the
line
and look what we're talking about is the
story behind the book the dichotomy of
leadership the dichotomy of leadership
is chapter 12 in extreme ownership so
cool we covered it
why do we have to write a whole new book
because people still like extreme
ownership
we gotta hold the line it's disciplined
and all kinds like
they took everything to the extreme and
that's why the story of the patches at
muster is so powerful
because people are like oh this is gonna
be awesome
jaco is going to hammer that platoon
and destroy them for violating his
direct order
to never wear patches that aren't
professional he's like not in care no
factor
like wait what it says right there hold
the line yeah
it's like yeah but actually living in
the extremes isn't
actually doesn't work yes it usually
doesn't work but the title of the book
is extreme ownership yeah so
well there you go there's perfect
examples that's what happened to klaus
fitz and he didn't even get to finish
his book
he wrote freaking three chapters and his
old lady finished it up
uh such a commandment gave reinforcement
to the instinctive conservatism of
soldiers in resisting the possibilities
of a new form of superiority which
mechanical invention increasingly
offered
it also gave powerful impulse to the
universal extension and permanently
permanent establishment of the method of
constrict
conscription as a simple way of
providing the greatest possible numbers
so if you want a big army if i want to
be in charge of a bunch of people
you know what i have to say look we need
more people if we're going to win cool
start drafting people i want to be in
charge of more people cool
draft more people this by its disregard
for psychological suitability meant that
armies became
much more liable to panic and sudden
collapse the earlier method however
unsystematic
had at least tended to ensure that the
forces were composed of
good fighting animals
[Music]
this is an interesting shot at klaus
switz
klaus wits contributed no new or
strikingly progressive ideas to tactics
or strategies
he was a codifying thinker rather than a
creative or dynamic one
he had no such revolutionary effect on
warfare as the theory of the divisional
system produced in the 18th century
or the theory of armored mobility in the
20th which by the way
that's what kind of ledell heart like is
about right so he said
look cosmos didn't do anything compared
to the theory of armored mobility
whoever came up with that
yeah well i feel bad i actually feel bad
talking about these guys talking
is that weird i didn't know how much of
a of a hammer
he was going to be on klaus the cool
thing is i'm hearing all this but
but i mean there is a lot of
i understand what he's saying i mean
yeah and again why didn't i
we're 286 episodes deep in this and i
haven't covered one of the
most respected and well-known canons of
military strategy yeah klaus switz is on
war
why is that this is kind of why yeah
oh boy i'm gonna catch some grief for
this one yup
going out just getting crazy well what's
interesting is that i think if you were
kind of just
pulse a bunch of it doesn't have to be
historians that are civilians but if you
look at
what the military and sort of key policy
makers study
klaus woods is higher on that list than
heart oh you know what i mean
so for sure not even the same ballpark
you may get some heat because
if there's someone that's been studied
and sort of kind of lionized
klaus woods is the guy you know what i
mean so yeah there's some people out
there going hey
well you know i've taken some heat over
the years i had a little guy named
colonel david hackworth who was a
complete black sheep of the army and
hated by the navy
totally and i was in the navy
talking about that guy um
back to the book but in seeking to
formulate the experience of
the napoleonic wars the emphasis he put
on certain retrograde
retrograde features helped to cause what
might be termed a revolution in reverse
back towards tribal warfare klaus was
theory of the military aim in defining
the military aim
klaus which was carried away by his
passion for pure logic
quote the and this this
makes it really uh this starts to make
it really obvious why this stuff doesn't
mend with my normal way of thinking
quote the aim of all action in war is to
disarm the enemy
and we shall now show that this in
theory at least is
indispensable if our opponent is to be
made to comply with our will we must
place him in a situation where
which is more oppressive to him than the
sacrifice we demand
but the disadvantages of this position
must naturally not be
of a transitory nature at least in
appearance otherwise the enemy instead
of yielding will hold out
in the hope of a change for the better
every change in this position
which is produced by a continuation of
war must therefore be a change for the
worse
worse the worst condition in which a
belligerent can be placed
is that of being completely disarmed if
therefore the enemy is to be reduced to
into submission he must either be
positively disarmed or placed in such a
position that he is threatened with it
from this follows that the complete
disarming or overthrow of the enemy
must always be the aim of warfare
end quote this reminds me of uh
the bath party in iraq being completely
disarmed how much did that help
freaking hurt right um
maybe some klaus whitsey and people were
saying yep gotta disarm him
yeah completely completely good job the
influence of
of kant kant where's where's daryl
cooper
daryl cooper is making jokes about like
he's just bringing in deep echo and i
are looking at him like bro
wrong crowd the influence of kant can be
perceived in klaus wit's dualism of
thought
he believed in a perfect military world
of ideals while recognizing a temporal
world in which these could only be
imperfectly fulfilled so he's giving
credit here's a little credit going back
to klaus where it's like hey man he got
it that you got these ideals but
it's the real world and it's not going
to quite go that well for he was capable
of distinguishing
between what was what was militarily
ideal and what he described as a
modification in the reality thus he
wrote
reasoning in the abstract the mind
cannot stop short of an extreme
but everything takes a different shape
when we pass from abstractions to
reality
this object of war in the abstract the
disarming of the enemy is
rarely attained in practice and is not a
condition necessary to peace so he
wasn't even saying what he was saying
he goes back and kind of backs off it a
little bit
koswitz's tendency to the extreme is
shown again in his discussion of battle
as a means to an to the end of war
he opened with the startling assertion
there is only one single means it
is the fight he justified this by a long
argument
to show that in every form of military
activity
quote the idea of fighting must
necessarily be at the foundation end
quote
having elaborately proved what most
people would be ready to accept without
argument klaus which said
the object of a combat is not always the
destruction of enemy forces
its object can often be attained as well
without the combat taking place at all
so there you go he's saying some of the
stuff that
that i do agree with
moreover klaus wits recognized that
quote the waste of our own military
forces must ceteris paribus
which means all things being equal
always be greater
the more our aim is directed upon the
destruction of the enemy's power
the danger lies in this that the greater
efficacy which we which we seek recoils
on ourselves and therefore has worse
consequences
in case we fail of success so he's got
some
he's got some quantifying statements
about his about his thoughts and
theories
out of his own mouth klaus wits here
gave a prophetic
verdict upon the consequences of of
following his own gospel in world war
one and two
for it was the ideal and not the
practical aspect of his teachings
on battle which survived he contributed
to this distortion
by arguing it was only to avoid the
risks of battle that quote
any other means are taken
so it's like we're trying to avoid
battle that's the only reason that we're
going to do anything else because we're
trying to avoid
battle and he fixed the distortion in
the minds of his pupils by hammering
on the abstract ideal and this is
here's our i guess i guess uh liddell
heart's just gonna go hot on everybody
he says not one reader and a hundred was
likely to follow the subtlety of his
logic
or to preserve a true balance amid such
philosophical jugglery
but everyone could catch such ringing
phrases as and here's where he gets a
the branded the the klaus wits branded
statements that that are uh click bait
here we go and they're freaking good to
go like you hear me like yeah
we have only one means in war the battle
the bloody solution of the crisis the
effort for the destruction of the
enemy's forces
is the firstborn son of war i mean come
on dude if you're in the military you're
eating these things up like
like a giant nice cool mulk
only great and general battles can
produce
great results let us hear not of
generals who conquer without bloodshed
right that's a
that's a quote from a guy that earlier
was saying like hey listen
you don't always want to go to war yeah
but but who remembers
hey sometimes you can use other means to
achieve victory i don't want to hear
that they want to hear
let us not hear of great generals who
conquer without bloodshed
so he branded himself but man
by the reiteration of such phrases klaus
wits blurred into the outlines of his
philosophy already indistinct and made
it into
mere marching refrain
um which in inflamed the blood
and intoxicated the mind in transfusion
it became a doctrine
fit to form corporals not generals
for by making battle appear quote the
only real warlike activity
end quote his gospel deprived strategy
of its laurels and reduced the art of
war to the mechanics of mass slaughter
moreover it incited generals to seek
battle at the first opportunity
instead of creating an advantageous
opportunity
cosworth contributed to the subsequent
decay of general ship
oh man when he when in an oft-quoted
passage he wrote
philanthropists may easily imagine that
there is a skillful method of disarming
and overcoming the enemy without great
bloodshed
and that is the proper tendency of the
art of war
that is an error which must be
extirpated
so like hey this idea of bloodshed we
gotta get rid of that idea
that you can that you can have war
without bloodshed you gotta get rid of
that idea
it is obvious that when he wrote that he
did not pause to reflect that what he
decried
had been recorded as the proper aim of
generalship by
all masters of the art of war including
napoleon himself
like everyone sun tzu napoleon everyone
in between like hey man if you can win
without fighting that's what we're doing
and he's saying the opposite
klaus woods phrase would henceforce be
used by countless
blunderers to excuse and even justify
their futile
squandering of life in bullheaded
assaults
the danger was increased because of the
way he constantly dwelt on the decisive
importance of a numerical superiority
with deeper penetration he pointed out
in one passage that surprise
lies quote at the foundation of all
undertakings for without it the
preponderance at the decisive point is
not
properly conceivable so that's what
we're talking about that's cool that's
maneuver warfare
but his disciples struck by his more
frequent emphasis
on numbers came to regard mere mass
as the simple recipe for victory
horrible and you know what
what's a similar idea to that is like my
rank right it's a rank
hey i outrank you that's my superiority
and that's what i'm going to use to lead
i mean that was that was brutal yeah
that was kind of a brutal
there's there's some little statements
that was like hey he also said this but
it's like uh when the general reads it
when the soldier reads it what does he
want to read he wants to read about
kicking ass yeah and what does he want
his corporals to read he wants his
corporals to read about kicking ass so
what do we start reading about kick and
ass yeah
we hear what we want to hear echo
charles yes sir
we're not done yet with call so it's
klaus what's theory of the object
even worse was the effectiveness
theoretical exposition
and exaltation of the idea of absolute
warfare income
in proclaiming that the road to success
was through the
unlimited application of force
thereby a doctrine which began by
defining war
only as a continuation of state policy
by other means led to the contradictory
end of making policy the slave of
strategy
and bad strategy at that you know that's
i would say that's one of his most
famous quotes right is that war is a
continuation of state policy by other
means
but he he he ends up
taking things to a point where it's like
war is what we're doing like you said
what the military exists for the
military
that everything else exists because of
the military yeah the government is here
to
provide the military with the resources
that we need to go fight battles
the trend was fostered above all by his
dictum that quote to
introduce into philosophy of war a
principle of moderation would be an
absurdity
war is an act of violence pushed to its
utmost bounds
dude he's getting some good quotes
therefore they sound kick ass
unless you're a freaking soldier in
world war one yeah
the crazy thing is i'm as i'm just kind
of picturing this i mean i'm asking
myself now a question that i probably
should have asked
five years ago 10 years ago when i was
thinking about this on a more
academic mind of of how did klauswitz
or any of these people that are i guess
disciples of that of that kind of pure
logic train
how did they perceive the value of their
own people
you know because you could see the train
of thought of like hey the this is the
the
the purpose of the military is the utter
destruction or what you know those those
quotes
where's the the the you could make a
very easy link of like hey
my soldiers they're just implementing
tools they're just resources to be
expended
to achieve that end state and how
quickly you can make the the stretch
like in world war one you can almost
imagine like yeah they're not
they're not people they're resources
they just give me 10 000 more resources
or more tools to accomplish this thing
yeah i
i mean you kind of phrased that as a
question i don't think there's much of a
question for sure i think it's pretty
obvious
where where these guys were coming from
and it's it's it's really scary that you
had a culture that supported that
and you had you know uh
you know it's like it's it's really
strange or you think about like kipling
and and kipling who wrote these very
patriotic poems
that fueled this culture inside of
england
and his son was killed
in in world war one and like the last
thing they saw of him was he's blinded
and he's kind of like
stumbling on the battlefield before he
was killed in his body
i don't think they ever even recovered
his body just lost in the mud and muck
and he's got a really harrowing poem
i think i i i know the phrase of the
poem is
is my boy jack or my son jack it's it's
it's harrowing to read and if you know
what the [ __ ] he's talking about
which is that he you know
he was this patriotic guy who
supported england and and
was contributing to that propaganda
this victorian this this this culture of
look look you go over the top it's time
to go you go and and
he lost his son and you wonder what kind
of
um
you know how that just the impact that
that had on him and
it there is an impact when you read his
poems and you see before and after you
see what happened
you can see that it definitely had an
impact but
the man the idea that
tens and thousands and hundreds of
thousands of of
people like you said like we're like
okay cool that's what we're doing
that's what we're doing we're gonna go
over there and
when they say go over the top we're
gonna go over the top the germans the
french
the canadians the americans the i mean
that's what we're doing
it's very very hard
you know you talk about the value of
life and your question around like what
do they think of these people it's like
yeah what did they and how did we get to
a point
where modern civilization
well this is a hundred years ago yeah
it's a hundred years ago
a hundred years ago this was happening
it's like it's crazy to think about
and uh and you can kind of see i mean
what's there's another good saying uh
it's uh something along the lines of
like old men
like to send young men to fight and
young men like to go fight like that's
kind of a thing
right and you can see how those
sort of animalistic instincts that we
have
and tribal instincts that we have are
and and the heroic instincts that we
have
are captured and capitalized on and
by leica koswitz like when you read
klaus which you're like
cool i'm down with heroic efforts i'm
down with
tribal behavior i'm down with
being brave like all those things just
roll right into this
so if you don't want to be that guy
that's sort of like well
maybe we should think about these
soldiers as human beings
who's doing that apparently no one
apparently no one
so what you have i guess what i'm saying
is you have
a human instinct and a human
animal instinct to be tribal to be
heroic to be sacrificial to make
sacrifices for the tribe
i mean what is a hero you know i've
talked about this before
a hero is someone that's not doing not
making a sacrifice for
himself right a hero is someone that's
making a sacrifice for someone else
and that's a common that's just the
definition of a hero
in any language so when you say hey
we've got kind of a program here that
allows us to be heroic on a massive
scale
this is what you end up with and we kind
of lean towards and we tend towards
and you can see how you can see how
the contrary is that you have bh liddell
hart who's saying hey not smart yeah
not smart it's better to maneuver it's
better to leave it's better to retreat
it's better to attack on a different day
and and how is he getting branded he's
getting branded like what the hell are
you talking about
were you a coward yeah is that what's
going on you're a coward he's like hey
bro i went wounded three times and
gassed almost to death you [ __ ]
savages
and you don't know what that was like
you talk about i don't know how many
times this has come up this
the the capacity for the dehumanization
of our enemies and how there's a danger
in there and there's
there's a natural piece of that but you
got to keep it to a
to a certain place but i think for me
just
that to reconcile the dehumanization of
your own men
i i understand the dehumanization of the
enemy i understand that
and i also understand that there is a
limit to that too and if you go too far
you can undermine your own objectives we
know that we know that
but the ability to do that with your own
men
your your own people is it's it
i think that's just why world war one
sort of
just sits in its own category of just so
hard to come to grips with
with us doing that
yeah it does it's it's in its own
category as far as i'm concerned yeah
right and i guess that's where we end up
with
these two kind of opposing
theories of war and
who wants to be called the wimp who
wants to be called the weak
right because that's where you could
easily go back to bh without heart and
say like
he wants to run away yeah he wants to
you know attack people from the rear
there's a time where attacking someone
in the rear shoot him in the back was
like a horrible thing right it's a sign
of cowardice yeah it's a sign of
cowardice to go around and
you know not line up like the other team
shoot him in the back yeah you know i
i've been
the coolest part about being on the
podcast in this seat is that this is i
hear this
live as you're reading it i don't i
don't get the advanced copy you don't
like say dave we're prepping this
i get to hear this and i i i'm i'm
thinking and i'm trying to analyzing i'm
making connections and correlations and
i've
kind of just been chuckling a little bit
of like heart is just hammering
klauswitz but he he
it's almost like i understand more now
of why he's so
brutal on the attack of him when he made
that connection of
he's the reason why we had generals
and i think he used the word blunders
which is about as nice as you can
describe
what those leaders did in world war one
is
i actually think i understand why he's
so brutal on him is because
of what it led to and and i don't and i
think he's doing a good job saying
i know klaus was his goal was not to
create this circumstance
and he's defending components of that
but his point was
this is the outcome that he created this
his words
and his philosophy is what facilitated
this
this window of warfare in our time
that allowed us to dehumanize our own
men
in on a scale that's really hard to
really comprehend
and and i think i'm understanding in
real time why he's saying what he's
saying about him in such a brutal
fashion
and i understand it yeah and i kicked
off this whole podcast
with the last podcast by explaining what
he'd been through and i
said this [ __ ] left a mark on him
i mean look it leaves a mark on you when
you lose one guy in combat one
one guy in combat is gonna leave him
you're never gonna forget it you're
never gonna live it down you're never
gonna go a day without thinking about it
can you imagine when your battalion gets
wiped out
yeah can you imagine when you're brigade
when you're division
when you take 60 000 casualties in a day
that's what's going on and
and the quote that you're reaching back
for was
klaus what's phrase would henceforce be
used by countless blunderers
to excuse and even justify
their feudal squandering of life in
bullheaded assaults yeah
he's talking about exactly what he lived
through
and that [ __ ] left a mark on him without
question
yeah and this is his
his opportunity to tell a generation of
leaders
contemplating the impact of that guy's
words
with the reality of without some logical
thinking about what he really is trying
to say
this is the path you will go down and
this is his way of saying
you cannot go down that path yeah you
want to go and read the
wave tops of this guy and turn it into
how you're going to fight a war right
you're an idiot
war is an act of violence pushed to its
upmost bounds that's the last quote i
give
he says that declaration has served as a
foundation for the extravagant
absurdity of modern total warfare his
principle of force without limit and
without calculation of
costs fits and is fit only
for a hate maddened mob so he's not done
yet
it is the negation of statementship and
intelligence strategy which seeks to
serve
the ends of policy if war
be a continuation of policy as switz had
elsewhere declared it it must
necessarily be
conducted with a view to post-war
benefit
a state which expands its strength to
the point of exhaustion
bankrupts its own policy and by the way
that's all players in world war one
koswitz himself had qualified the
principle of quote utmost force
by the admission that quote the
political object
as the original motive of war should be
the standard for determining both the
aim of the military force
and also the amount of effort to be made
still more significant was a reflective
passage in which he remarked
that to pursue the logical extreme
entailed that
quote the means would lose all relation
to the end and in most cases
the aim at an extreme effort would be
wrecked
by the opposite weight of forces within
itself
what's the rule what's the return on
investment you're going to get
his classic work on war was the product
of 12 years of intensive thought
if it's author had lived to spend a
longer time in thinking about
war he might have reached a wiser and
clearer conclusion
as his thinking progressed he was being
led toward
a different view penetrating deeper
unhappily
the process was cut short by his death
from cholera in 1830 it was only after
his death that his writings on war were
published by his widow
they were found in a number of sealed
packets bearing the significant and
prophetic note so he wrote a note
on his writings and it said should the
work
be interrupted by my death then what is
found can only be called a mass of
conceptions
not brought into form open to
endless misconceptions sorry klaus wits
i mean he
covered it he did his best to cover it
yeah
much of the harm might have been avoided
but for that fatal cholera germ
for there are significant indications
that in the gradual evolution of his
thought he had reached a point where he
was about to drop his original concept
of absolute war and revise his whole
theory on more common sense lines
when death intervened in consequence the
way was left open to endless
misconceptions far in excess of his
anticipation
for the universal adoption of the theory
of unlimited war has gone
far to wreck civilization the teaching
of klaus wits
taken without understanding largely
influenced
both the causation and the character of
world war one
thereby it led on all too logically
to world war ii
theory influx next section after world
war one the course and effects of the
first world war provided ample cause to
doubt the validity of clausewitz theory
at least interpreted by his successors
on land innumerable battles were fought
without ever producing the decisive
results expected of them
but the responsible leaders were slow to
adapt their aim to circumstances
or develop new means to make the aim
more possible
and maybe that's why when he was going
through the eight um
items that we were talking about earlier
on the earlier podcast
his number one thing remember you're
saying the number one thing was his
number eight thing
his number one thing was adjust your
adjust your end to your means and here
he's saying the responsible leaders were
slow to adapt their aim to the
circumstances
or develop new means to make the aim
more possible
instead of facing the problem they
pressed theory to a suicidal extreme
draining their own strength beyond the
safety limit in pursuit of an ideal
of complete victory by battle which was
never fulfilled
that one side ultimately collapsed that
one side ultimately collapsed so the
germans ultimately collapsed
do more to emptiness of stomach produced
by economic pressure of sea power
than the loss of blood although blood
which was lost in the abortive germ
german offensive 1918 and the loss of
spirit and consequence of their palpable
failure to gain the victory
hasten the collapse if this provided
the opposition the opposing nations with
the semblance of victory
their efforts to win it cost them
such a price in moral and physical
exhaustion that they
the seeming victors were left incapable
of consolidating their position
it became evident there was something
wrong with the theory or at least with
its application
alike on the planes of the tactics
strategy and policy
the appalling losses
suffered in vain pursuit of the ideal
objective
and the post-war exhaustion of the
nominal victors
showed that a thorough re-examination of
the whole problem
of the object and aim was needed
besides these negative factors there
were also several several
positive reasons to prompt a fresh
inquiry one was the decisive
part that seapower had played without
any decisive battle
at sea and producing the enemies
collapsed by economic pressure
that raised the question whether britain
in particular had not made a basic
mistake in departing from her
traditional strategy
and devoting much of her effort at such
terrific cost to herself to the
prolonged attempt to win a decisive
victory on land
yeah england freaking survived forever
just by rolling ruling the sea britannia
rules the waves
that's what we do in england now we're
over here fighting these
these people on land
two other reasons arose from the new
factors
the development of air forces offered
the possibility of striking account
the enemy's economic and moral centers
without having to first achieve the
destruction of the enemy's
main forces on the battlefield air power
might attain a direct
end by indirect means hopping over
opposition
instead of overthrowing it good deal
dave
i mean that's always been the goal
whether it's whether it's ever going to
prove to be true
you could make a couple arguments but
that's always been the goal we can do
this without actually fighting
on the ground on the ground yeah
at the same time so at the same time we
have air power at the same time the
combined development of the petrol motor
and the caterpillar track opened up a
prospect of developing mechanized land
forces of high mobility
this in turn foreshadowed a newly
enlarged possibility of producing the
collapse of the enemy's main forces
without a serious battle
by cutting their supply lines
dislocating their control systems
or producing paralysis by the sheer
nerve shock of deep penetration in the
rear seat also you got vehicles
that can haul ass not get shot up and
move a bunch of troops in a short amount
of time
mechanized land forces of this new kind
might also provide like air power
though in a lesser degree the
possibility of striking direct
at the heart and nerve system of the
opposing country
while air mobility could achieve such
direct strokes by an
overhead form of indirect approach tank
mobility might achieve them by
indirect approach on the ground avoiding
the obstacle of the opposing army
to illustrate the point by a board game
analogy with chess
air mobility introduced the knights move
and tank mobility of queens move
into warfare analogy does not of course
express their respective values
for an air force combined with the
vaulting power of the knights move
with the always flexibility of the
queen's move
on the other hand a mechanized force a
mechanized ground force
though it lacked vaulting power could
remain an occupation of the square
it gained
a couple other things
these these new these new technologies
increase the range of military action
against military objectives making it
easier to overthrow an opposing
body such as an army by by paralyzing
some of its vital organs instead of
having to destroy
it physically as a whole by hard
fighting if you could you could knock
out some of the key nodes
that's going to be better the some
effect
of the advent of this multiplied
mobility both on the ground and in the
air was to increase the power and
importance of strategy relative to
tactics
the higher commanders of the future
would have the prospect
of achieving decisive results much more
by
movement than by fighting compared with
their predecessors
unfortunately though skipping ahead a
little bit unfortunately those who were
at the head of the armies after world
war one were slow to recognize
the need of a fresh definition of the
military aim
in light of changed conditions and war
instruments
i mean you should be absolutely
rethinking every
you imagine going from not having tanks
and aircraft to having tanks and
aircraft
you should be completely changing the
entire way you're thinking about warfare
and by the way this is after world war
one right
you know we did a piece we did a podcast
on the boor war
and they learned all these lessons
during the boomer war and they freaking
didn't capitalize on any of them
like world war one shouldn't happen just
based on what they learned in world war
in the boomer war
i'm going extreme i don't want to go
this extreme there are many lessons that
that were learned
during the boor war that they could have
taken back and said we need to do things
differently
and they didn't freaking adjust very
many of them at all
well going back to the last podcast and
one of the first comments he made
about the the the natural
resistance the the automatic resistance
that will happen
when you propose change and i'm
paraphrasing i don't remember the exact
quote but the idea that when i
suggest a change to the norm there will
be there will be resistance
you know one thing to call me even a
hist
an amateur is is a compliment but
i even think about you know the advent
of air power and the resistance even in
the navy
to the idea that air power would somehow
supplant the battleship as the
preeminent
force
and how obvious it seems now certainly
but at the time you're thinking hey do
you not
can you not see the the potential
advantage if we could somehow occupy
this third dimension of battle
exclusively
and how much risk it creates and the
resistance and my guess would be is that
for the few folks that have the audacity
to vocalize those lessons
oh run out of the navy and by the way
remember the last podcast when i talked
about
17 out of 20 advancements in naval
warfare
one of them was aircraft carriers and
air power totally that's one of the more
people
are you kidding me we have a battleship
bro right back off
yeah it's it's
this book is getting harder and harder
to listen to
it because yeah because the because i
have the the his
the hindsight of his of of what he's
saying in the context of that which he
he didn't have the future context that
we all have now but
it's making it just so much more damning
to he you know what he's saying
fast forward a little bit practice in
world war ii
when the next war came the handful of
new land forces of mechanized kind that
had been created amply fulfilled the
claims that have been made for them
and for their decisive effect if
employed for long-range strokes
at strategic objectives
unfortunately it's the nazis that are
just going to say yeah a mere six
divisions of this kind were largely
instrumental in
producing the collapse of poland in a
few weeks um
a mere 10 such divisions virtually
decided the so-called battle of france
before the infantry
mass of the german army had even come in
action and made
the collapse of all western countries an
almost
inevitable sequel this conquest of the
west was completed in barely a month's
campaign
with amazingly small costs to the victor
indeed the
bloodshed all around was very slight and
in the
decisive phase trifling by a klaus
witsian
standard i mean can you imagine you
fight those
freaking three bloody satanic
battles i mean campaigns in world war
one
just incomprehensible and then fast
forward
how many years 20 years 20 years 20
years 22 years whatever
and it's over in less than a month like
that's what we're talking about and
there's almost no bloodshed because it
just happened so fast
because we have maneuver on our side
yeah even
and even in between those two examples
not not to marginalize you know what
the germans did to to poland but
it's what happened to the french that
seems to me more remarkable because
because of of what they had just been
through
and then to see i mean the image of of
hitler at the eiffel tower i mean
like that's a that's a
it's hard to put into words what that
means for him to be standing there with
with
with basically no real cost of doing it
relative
uh crazy crazy while this sweeping
victory was attained by
action against objectives of military
nature it was mainly through action of
maneuver
strategic more than tactical so it's a
different he's playing a different game
yeah playing a different game
similar reflections apply to the even
swifter conquest of the balkans
in april of 1941 which once again
demonstrated the paralyzing effect of
the new instruments
of strategic application battle was
insignificant in comparison
and destruction palpably an appropriate
term for the way that the decision was
achieved
when it came to the invasion of russia a
somewhat different method was tried
many of the german generals particularly
halder
the chief of the general staff complain
of hitler's tendency to aim at the
economic
rather than military objectives but
analysis of the operational orders and
of their own
evidence does not bear out the charge
while hitler was inclined to think that
the economic aim would be more effective
it is clear that in the crucial period
of 1941 campaign
he conformed to the general staff's
preference for fighting battles
thankfully thank god yeah the pursuit of
this aim did not prove
decisive although it produced several
great victories
in which immense forces of the enemy
were destroyed okay
we went and killed a bunch of russians
whether concentration on economic
objectives would have been more decisive
remains an open question but the
reflection that some of the ableist
of the german generals consider that the
best chance of defeating soviet russia
was lost by aiming to win battles in the
classical way
instead of driving through as fast as
possible to the
moral come economic objectives offered
by mascot moscow and leningrad
the leading exponent or gordian the
leading exponent of the new school of
mechanical mobile warfare wish to do
on this key question hitler had cited
with the orthodox school
like we said thank god
in the series of swift german conquest
the air force combined with the
mechanized elements of land forces in
producing the paralysis and moral
disintegration of the opposing forces
and of nations behind its effect was
terrific
and must be reckoned fully as important
as that of the panzer forces
the two are inseparable in any valuation
of the elements that created the new
style of lightning war for
warfare the blitzkrieg
so i'm going to fast forward a little
bit there's a section in here
about strategic bombing
and and what he calls grand strategic
bombing or industrial bombing and he
kind of goes into
into how effective actually how
effective it actually was he says the
the actual effect
which this kind of bombing achieved in
contribution to victory is very
difficult to assess despite much
detailed investigation the estimation
of the data is confused bipartisan
estimate
assessments both by those who favored
industrial bombing
and those who opposed it on various
grounds apart from the fog thus created
a correct assessment is handicapped
and made almost impossible by the amount
of
imponder bilia in the data
even more than the evidenced about
any other type of military action
imponderabilia
meaning things that can't be determined
so he's basically saying that some of
the industrial
bombing may have not have been effective
as we thought it was
fast forward a little bit still clear is
the extremely detrimental effect of
industrial bombing on the post-war
situation again we're going to think
grand strategy we've got to think about
what's happening afterwards
beyond the immense scale of devastation
hard to repair are the less
obvious but probably more lasting social
and moral effects
this kind of action inevitably produces
a deepening danger
to the relative shallow foundations of
civilized
life think about what you're doing to
this civilian populace
and how is that going to affect the
future
that common danger is now immensely
increased by the advent of the atomic
bomb
here we are brought to the fundamental
difference between
strategy and grand strategy whereas
strategy
is only concerned with the problem of
winning military victory
grand strategy must take the longer view
for its problem is the winning of the
peace
such an order of thought is not
a matter of putting the cart before the
horse
but of being clear where the horse and
cart
are going
and i'll tell you what with that we're
approaching two hours right now we're
probably really close if not at two
hours
and we have a lot more to cover
so echo is it cool if we wrap this one
up for now
sure all right so
we'll come back to you one more podcast
about this book
and well about these books
until then until then and look we're
going deep right now
we're we're drinking some we're drinking
some drinks
uh we're getting after it how do we get
these drinks we're drinking
what are we doing you just cracked
another one open sure
where do we go actually real quick i had
a thought that so klaus switz
and liddell hart they're kind of like
your watch karate kid
yes the og original karate kid john
crease
mr miyagi okay yep so crossfits
klaus bits or klaus wits depends on what
kind of an
accent i'm kind of like attempting but
gotcha so he's john crease
strike first strike hard no mercy like
kind of that philosophy wait that's mr
miyagi no that's
john crease oh okay you know kind of the
bad guy but yeah he'll get you fired up
he'll get you fired up the fight
let's face it we all want to say no
mercy in this dojo yeah i kind of like
that
fear does not exist in this dojo jack
right all this stuff so it gets you
fired up you know but mr miyagi for 42nd
by the way
oh really using for real life no okay in
the story
i got a book about the 442nd i got to
get a better one i got one of it as a
history book
and it was cool and somebody sent it to
me and i was kind of stoked like yeah
but it was a history book
wasn't a lot of first person i was like
cool we can do history book as long as a
bunch of first person accounts
really wasn't that many in there i got
to get i got to get on the 442nd
i dig it nonetheless mr miyagi his whole
thing was
balanced right takes daniel's son out on
the river
or the lake and he has him on the boat
right balance first before
he's like when do i learn how to fight
all this stuff what else did he say
why i learned karate and he was like
so you don't have to fight whatever the
balance man
it's what it seemed like to me i don't
know i think there you go
provided some more okay here i am
reading these books and you're just
getting it from a karate kid
you could have figured it all out yeah
that's true nonetheless
you are right we are here drinking
discipline go
sometimes you gotta drink discipline go
yeah that's good unless last time i was
saying how
now the path is a little bit easier
thing is i don't know if the path is
actually easier because easy easy is not
the right word
maybe it's comfortable okay that doesn't
sound like the right word either
because like comfort do you want to be
cable you want to be comfortable
nonetheless it's more pleasurable how
about that we're drinking discipline go
it tastes good it's good for you it's a
win-win strategically and tactically
okay i think
all this stuff is bringing it all
together along those lines
all right same thing with milk you can
have something that tastes really really
good plus provides protein plus it's
healthy
boom this is all the jocko fuel stuff so
also we got your joint stuff
uh your immunity stuff joint warfare
super krill oil
vitamin d3 and cold water
that's true get these things at
jackalfuel.com get the discipline go
energy
drinks i'm just gonna call them energy
drinks just for
because that's what we're doing drinking
the energy drinks
get those at wawa and vitamin chop
actually you can get everything from
from vitamin c by the way also yes
or at jockofield.com get the
subscription if you don't want to get uh
if you want you don't want to forget
about um you know
just restock check it out if you
subscribe to whatever you want from
jogglefuel
shipping's free and shipping can be
expensive let's face it
and we want to not expend resources that
we don't have to
that's true a little indirect attack get
subscription
all of a sudden shipping is free
it's true your resources are spared and
can be utilized for other
offensive operations yeah that's kind of
like a kind of badass way of saying that
right
yeah kind of i agree i agree yeah yeah
fully also speaking of operations origin
usa
american made stuff durable goods
clothing
what that means is you want to get some
american-made jeans made out of
american-made denim made out of
american-made cotton
origin usa that's where you can get this
stuff also has athletic wear some uh
jiu jitsu stuff geez rash guards belts
wallets
boots i still have your boots by the way
oh
i think i'm gonna need those soon yeah
don't worry they're downstairs in the
car
nonetheless origin usa that's where you
can get this stuff real good stuff it's
a big deal too made in america the way
it is made in america from the beginning
all the way up into the final product
yeah
we have a factory full of awesome
american people
up there creating this stuff sewing it
printing it i mean just every aspect
cutting it
sewing it it's just legit and if you
follow that
if you if you pull the thread on a pair
of jeans you're going to end up in a
cotton field in
in texas or in georgia like that's where
it's coming from
so know your roots
it's true speaking of roots also jackal
has a store
that's his roots it's called jocko store
that's where you can get the discipline
equals freedom
or good or get after it all you can get
the shirts the hats
hoodies
some rash guards on there stuff a bunch
of stuff anyway yeah check that one out
it's at jackostore.com and yeah if you
like something get something
we also have a subscription situation
there called the short locker
if you want a cool kind of off shoot
conceptual designs
i don't think you've really figured out
how to describe your designs yet
no it's a work in progress i see but
each time you got to progress
you haven't progressed your description
yeah but just like um what do you call
uh warfare yeah you know you don't
you're not always progressing you see
i'm saying but you want
some sometimes you go forward sometimes
you go backwards you know hopefully the
whole grand uh what do you call
freaking grand strategy yeah
hopefully i end up forward hopefully i
end up achieving the goal
of explaining how cool the shirt locker
is
so you already did a better job right
there you just needed a little help
a little help okay good some criticism
some direct feedback about your weak ass
repetition i'm over here trying and you
know and i think the people are
responding
you know people seem to like it i gotta
admit when
we were at the muster and i saw some
people that had
you know shirt locker shirts on totally
representing extra level
of connection yeah yep i agree i felt
the exact same thing
anyway yeah sherlock that's at
dropletstore.com so yeah sign up for
that if you're down
yeah you can subscribe to this podcast
too we also have jockle unraveling
podcast that i'm doing with
daryl cooper who knows what's gonna
happen we're getting crazy on that thing
got all kinds of topics we're digging
into um
we don't always agree on stuff let's
come come to find out
in dc sometimes it gets a little hectic
in the podcast room
uh check out that the jocko unraveling
podcast check out the grounded podcast
check out the warrior kid podcast you
can also
check out we have another alternative
podcast called
jocko underground you can go to
jockowunderground.com
if you want to hear some amplifying
information if you want to hear
some other topics that are adjacent to
yet not fully embedded with jocko
pondcast topics
but look even though i think about
leadership
20 hours a day there's other
things i think about like psychology
like sociology
like questions do answering questions
from people so there's a lot of stuff
going on that
also gives us the opportunity to have an
alternative platform
besides the mainstream platforms which
we do not control
we we don't mind you know being on those
platforms
but they could make moves that would we
would mind
that we would not appreciate and we know
you wouldn't appreciate
so in order to prevent us from being in
a situation that we have lost total
control we have some contingency plans
it's called jocko underground
jockowinderground.com
you can join we'll get you this little
extra podcast
costs eight dollars and 18 cents a month
that way we have it if we need it and if
you can't afford it it's cool
we still got your back you know email
assistants at jockowunderground.com
we've got a youtube channel
where i am the assistant director for
many of the videos
and hence some of the videos have very
high quality some of them that i don't
work on
a little bit subpar but cool echo's
working on it
he's working on improving yeah
so there you go uh psychological warfare
it's an album jack
album with chocolate tracks where you
know if you want to skip the workout you
want to cheat on the diet when you're
having those feelings
you need some help boom jacqua's there
to help get you through those moments of
weakness
sort of play the tracks boom and around
we go
you can get those anywhere you get mp3s
that's where you can get them amazon
google play all those
places and don't forget about
flipsidecanvas.com if you want to hang
some cool stuff on your wall which you
probably do
things that remind you of the path
go to flipsidecampus.com dakota meyer
imagine having something from dakota
myers hanging in your house
it was freaking just legit
if you think about dakota meyer you just
be like cool i'm gonna
i'm gonna get after it that's true right
that's what i think yeah
fully you know what's funny dakota
dakota and i when we talk
we will have conversations and that we
will be laughing hysterically about
stuff
he's not surprised he actually makes me
laugh
harder than anyone currently in my
uh regime of contacts interesting
yeah theo vaughn huh theo can crazy up
too that's true
yeah that's a good point but it's a
different kind yeah yeah yeah it's true
uh
you know what theo will getting me to
laugh get me laughing
on a tactical level sure with with
with playing with dakota man sometimes
we're laughing at us strategic
deep level uh yeah so we got that
flipsidecampus.com dakota meyer we also
got a bunch of books
final spin it's a
book poem manuscript transcript
new form new format of literature sure
notice how i said that new format of
literature my wife says literature
because she's british
literature yeah so a new form of
literature which i
invented the text text
you got to go oh yeah if you want to
observe the text that's the eyebrow yeah
deal no no you don't know about that guy
yeah you taught me that did i teach you
that that's what they say did you they
say that in uh
when you went to get your masters or
they say if you if you
if you reference the text in this
situation like they don't call it a book
because you're just like a loser if you
just have a book you have to refer to
the text
yeah the text yeah we don't like that
anyways if you want to check out the
text you can check out final spin
you can pre-order it right now also
leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocols
disciplinary freedom field manual way
the warrior kid one two and three mike
and the dragons about faced by hackworth
extreme ownership of the dichotomy of
leadership
just all the things that we're talking
about when it comes to leadership and
all these different books
also speaking of leadership we have a
leadership consultancy what do we do
dave
we solve problems through leadership but
aren't but
what about problems that aren't really
leadership related
all your problems are leadership
problems isn't that crazy
it's true if you want us to come and
help you inside your organization go to
echelonfront.com
we also have an online training program
efonline.com it's extreme
ownership academy we have we have
courses on every chapter we have
live q and a's that we do we have
leadership primers
we have questions today we got we had a
forum on there we got all kinds of stuff
on there
to help you with the most important
skill that a human being can have which
is leadership
leadership can prevent things like
freaking the battle of the song
check muster
2021 orlando done
next up phoenix august 17th and 18th las
vegas
october 28th and 29th these are our
leadership conferences
come and get it we also have the ftx
where you where you get your gear on
get set up with a high speed laser tag
gun get taught some of the basic tactics
military tactics and then you go with
your team
and you conduct operations
you put these strategies and tactics and
principles that we talk about all the
time you put them to use
and you see how they work out and you
learn
and you get debriefed so if you want to
do that
check out the ftx san diego july 12th
and 13th go to ashlandfront.com
if you want to help service members
active and retired their families gold
star families you can check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization
and if you want to donate or you want to
get involved go to america's
mightywarriors.org and if you want
more of my exhaustive explanations or
you need more
of echo's disjointed delirium
perhaps you need more of dave's
exhilarated expositions
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter on the gram and on facebook
echoes with charles dave is that david
r burke and i am at jocko willink
and to all the military personnel out
there
thank you for taking these tactics that
we are
talking about and putting them to work
around the world to keep us free and the
same to our police law enforcement
firefighters paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service and all first responders
thank you for keeping us safe here at
home
and to everyone else out there
well if you know
the way broadly you see it in all things
so i've got an idea try your best
to open up your eyes look around
and see the way in everything that you
do
and until next time this is dave and
echo
and out